hi steve coffin here uh
i'm gonna do another video
right behind the one that i just did
about listening versus speaking because
there's been a
quite a bit of reaction both at my blog
the linguist on language blog
and at youtube
and uh
the original video that i put up was
about why i tend to favor listening
as the sort of area where we should
spend most of our time in learning a
language listening and reading in other
words input activities rather than
speaking and so i had a variety of
reactions and i'm going to i've got them
listed out here and if i can read my
writing i'm going to comment on them all
um
the first one
was first of all i will preface um
everything that i'm going to say
by pointing out that to me the the
fundamental task in language learning is
to acquire words and that's why at link
lingq.com we measure the number of words
you know
and to me knowing a word means
understanding it it's it's perfectly
normal that we should have a much larger
passive vocabulary than active
vocabulary it's that's good because we
need to understand what people say to us
we can always use a more limited
vocabulary to express our own thoughts
but if we don't understand the words
that people are using
in our reading or our listening then we
are going to have a very tough time
so passive vocabulary that's the key
that's what i like to build up and i
know that eventually some of these will
convert into active words and probably i
need to use them for them uh to become
active also some people say well it's
not words it's phrases or it's chunks
perhaps and i believe in that i think we
need to learn chunks of the language we
need to learn learn phrases
uh but phrases are consist of words so
it still boils down to words counting
the number of words that you
know
i'm not a big believer in the idea of
saving a bunch of sentences because to
me every sentence is different unique i
like
i do like studying phrases but whether
it be sentences which some people prefer
or phrases we're talking about words you
need to know words
so
uh now some of the issues that came up
peop some people
like the idea of speaking from the
beginning and there are a number of
people on the internet who have quite a
a following like moses mccormick
uh and of course benny
and now vince here at street smart
uh and there are uh other learners who
tell me that they really like
you know systems like pimsleur or
michelle thomas because they get you
speaking early
personally
i don't think it's very important to
speak early what matters is how soon do
you
reach a level that i would call fluency
because that's my goal typically fluency
i want to get there as quickly as i can
fluency does not mean being able to say
hello how are you where's the bathroom
can i have a beer
or may i have this dance although those
are useful things to know how to do and
you can get there pretty quickly
fluency to me is the ability to express
yourself comfortably
on a number of subjects in particular
subjects that you're familiar with
i can't discuss
automobile mechanics in a number of
languages but most of the subjects that
i'm familiar with
i can discuss in the language that i
languages that i claim to be fluent in
to become fluent you need to have a lot
of words because fluent implies
conversation dialogue it implies
understanding what the other person is
saying
so
whether after one or two or three months
i can say something in the new language
doesn't really matter to me
obviously if i'm in a place where native
speakers of that language are readily
available i will attack them with
whatever i have
and just for fun because it's fun we
want to try stuff out but the
vast majority of my learning time and
this was the case when i lived in japan
was spent listening and reading and
building up up my vocabulary so that i
can understand what people say to me
so
those people who are more concerned
about speaking early they will like
pimsleur
or michelle thomas because they get you
saying things whether that
takes you to where you're going to be
fluent is another question
i think a lot of people are
uncomfortable being in that sort of
situation of uncertainty in the language
it's not clear it's i can't pronounce it
properly i make mistakes i can't express
myself
uh
and so therefore they they want to have
a little more certainty
and i saw one commenter kate
said that she's going to take lessons
because she's been listening and she
still can't say very much in french so
she's going to go to a tutor
to me if i followed her argument or not
her points and then damien came in with
some suggestions of various sources of
of learner content
and damian said he was on nasimil for
six months and kate said she'd been
listening for i don't know how many
months but many many months and damien
recommended you know
various learner items well
me personally after two months i don't
want to be on learner content after two
months i want to be on stuff of interest
and challenging myself and listening
repeatedly if necessarily and necessary
and everything that i listened to victor
said well how do you learn if you just
listen well yeah everything you listen
to you've got to read and therefore
until i am very good i can't access
podcasts for where for which there are
no transcripts and that's why at link we
all of our content has both audio and
transcripts and then i worked the
transcripts in the old days i used to
use readers with wordless now i use on
link our dictionaries and i save the
words and review them in flashcards so
that the listening that i'm listening to
now for enjoyment and out of interest
after the first couple of months that's
what's driving me to increase my
vocabulary a couple of other comments
shadowing i don't do shadowing a lot of
people swear by it that's fine and
people have their own ways of learning i
listen because i find the subject
interesting the first two months i'm
forced to listen to less interesting
content although we have at link some
beginner content that's paralleled in
all 10 languages and i spent a good part
of two months listening to who is she a
story in 26 episodes in russian where i
knew what the story was in english and i
saved words and phrases so the first two
months you're listening to boring stuff
but beyond that i'm listening for
meaning so i'm not interested in
shadowing i'm listening for meaning and
then i'm reading and then i'm saving the
words and reviewing them in my
flashcards another person asked do you
vocalize yes i vocalize sub-vocalize uh
in foreign languages i think we all do
it until we get so fluent in that
language that we can read it like our
own and so
the advantage of having the audio before
you read something is that you've got
some momentum going into the reading you
know roughly what it's about
uh and you it's easier than to sub
vocalize you've got that rhythm going
and so you're trying to read up to that
rhythm the rhythm that you were
listening to so yes i sub-vocalize and i
benefit a lot from having listened to
something beforehand
one person said how much russian do you
understand after three years well
basically i understand it all if i know
the words but they're still
according to the link five ten percent
of words that are new to me but i i know
where the word begins and ends i may not
know every word so i'm constantly
working to improve my vocabulary but
most of the interviews at ekko muskri
if i pick up tolstoy i have no trouble
reading him if i pick up
an author that i'm less familiar with i
will encounter more unfamiliar
vocabulary and so it'll be more
difficult um somebody said where are the
beginner resources um you got to look
for them but we have a lot at link so
you can try out link and it's all audio
and text
somebody said where do you find
audiobooks on history well please let me
know which
languages you're interested in uh
hermann lindquist is a favorite of mine
for swedish you can google him
there's all kinds of russian audiobooks
you can google for that
uh leave a fun in
for french is very good
tell me which languages you're
interested in and i will let you know
but generally speaking googling
audiobooks
will do it for you um what else did i
have on here
uh someone said that we need to speak in
order to train the mouth to form
whatever i don't believe that i think
you can do that training after after
your brain is more familiar with the
sound why struggle trying to form these
difficult sounds drastwiche and russian
when the brain isn't yet used to it you
can pronounce things much better once
you can hear them once you're more
attentive to the sounds so train the
mouth if you want i don't i think
i don't know i'm perhaps in chinese i
did that a bit but that can come later
on so i try i think i stayed within the
10 minutes i look forward to more
comments thank you